jerry get out damn it jerry
sorry you're the victim sorry sorry damn
jerry
you jumped in a creek for burrito what'd
you do for a klondike bar kill your wife
figure it out jerry wow don't be such a
jerry ben
jerry what the hell i didn't do this
jerry can you please be quiet
damn it jerry oh that sounds like the
newlywed game shut up jerry what about
my poem no one wants you to read a poem
okay jerry
forget it macklin you're too late i'm
sorry guys i
i i need my cheaters jerry i am making
you
my number two guy on the new font
project come on that's too close let's
make him my number three
fair enough jerry you're number three
there's only two of us most of the
credit goes to my number four
jerry gary gergich
jerry gergich gary gergich jerry gergich
gary gergich jerry god they're both
horrible
damn it jerry you just had to do your
job didn't you yeah can't you do
anything wrong
jerry oh damn you jerry it is not my
fault
city council [ __ ]
[Applause]
jerry forgot to vote damn it jerry
god jerry you don't deserve the internet
no jeez did a dinosaur dysphoric jerry
get a grip
sorry guys damn it jerry you're nasty
jerry
you guys doing experiments on jerry yes
cool
gross jerry hello leslie it's jerry
jerry who gerge oh jerry jerry why are
you calling me
take a hike jerry it's larry now okay
take a hike larry i got a pizza
time it's a pizza time larry everyone is
miserable
and you are only making it worse are you
in a cult
can i join let's sacrifice larry now is
not the time larry please leave
no no damn it larry
sorry larry larry larry
listen to me this is the worst thing
you've ever done
damn it terry gary i take everything
back i hate you
i've decided to finally retire this is
about people who are moving gary not
everything is about you good point
come on gary you're the mayor now have
some dignity
time listen to me if there's one thing
i've learned
thank you i miss you guys
you